now what I was your collision we defined
the absolute value in a variety of
different ways the particular way when
we're pushing along with this one we
hosted at any point of three is equal to
what is kicking at different times
sometimes it's just regular old X minus
three
when is defecation when when that B is
positive play and alternatively if that
thing is no positive than you slap a
minus sign on it which means in this
case use to September it's become 3 1 X
ok now what this gets introduced
something you have maybe encountered
just in a life as a side note before but
what this means is the y equals the
absolute value of x times 3 is what I
call the C scale function piecemeal
function who's heard of the phrase
piecemeal function of all hands up
straight and not just a small number of
your hands down ok here's why people
function works they don't draw this just
let me show you what it usually we
actually grab something and we say ok
grab this C is equal to X plus 4 x
squared minus 1 whatever and you draw it
but something in reality is nature in
artificial systems they don't just
follow one function not just to make
money for not just X square minus 1 but
sometimes they do is sometimes they do
that as an example I could say why
two different dishes but X if X is
resident return and X square it is
political climate change just think
about it in pieces apart for people just
think about the negative values of X
what did this graph look like straight
line yes it's on that guy have you see
why I've been it's all part of it I've
only drawn one piece of it I've only
drawn the plot that satisfies this
domain restriction X is not very queer
oh okay what I did when X is on the line
is I want it positive we know what rebel
looks like it looks like that now I know
listen it mean what one computes to that
and the point is doesn't matter we can
define to be whatever we want and that's
vacation so noting that it is free being
greater than or equal is the same as X
being presented for free and noting that
this is the same as exercising free you
can see if you look great kind of an
important point right
just like here x equals zero is the
junction between two different functions
x equals three is the junction over here
so let's just mark in X's now if you go
ahead and think about it again in
students going down X minus three
it's going to look like big I just went
through the light if I drew the whole
thing and we continue across and it was
hit the y-axis really Zuleika and we're
his down at negative three wouldn't it
but I wanted you've seen that part this
part is much harder than me so I'm going
to get rid of it now for the rest to the
domain when X is less than 3
I don't draw that graph I draw this one
what that was told you described mmm
yeah I can see some hands going on okay
doing this boy huh it's just anyone you
know what it was a hot oven get to like
what you reckon maker is crazy okay it's
going to be looking down is it
it happens to be putting down exactly
opposite have it split option and what
will be permission its own a wife at all
three listen if I draw a line
their day which is why many people when
they chose me absolute values and start
wrapping them we start to think about
value graph there's a bouncy graphs
right it's like it's closer coming down
and then for me it's just going to
rebound off the x-axis okay the x does
look like that but really what's going
on is there are actually two your
procedure this is a very cheerful and
high function sometimes this other times
that just a physical I have now two
well-defined
branches of my absolute value function
and later on your feet sometimes you can
have two or three or four or any number
you want it's going to be very helpful
each carefully label which one is which
so this was an excellent three this one
is three minus F now before we leave off
this lovely new graph I'm going to use
this result as secondary question do you
remember yesterday I gave you the review
questions they before them and they came
in ten you remember that I shoulda graph
and then solve an inequality grasp and
solve an inequality please do the same
thing here what gets on the basis of
this graph I am impressed
Oh
he has begun
now do you remember when we were looking
at solving equations like this you could
use the five cases you can do it like a
that's fun but if you've got a picture
already you might as well use the
picture so I'm trying to train when you
read this to see this now another color
there because what I can do is I've
already graphed Y you back now on the
same set of axes I'm going to wrap this
and and it's just a horizontal line
looks like it's going to go through
somewhere lies
sir I standing at the Livia what is this
asking in visual turn with me yeah
yeah so in in visual terms less than or
equal to me below right below you can
see the y-value can we compare okay so
you can come to our picture frame this
part down here to be part is valid okay
it's all one it is quality okay so so
long as you're between here and TR your
voice well let's work out we're here in
CDs on the graph you can actually go
down because it's a very simple graph
exactly what criminal element you know
she should read that off what numbers
that this should be negative one right
like it so gradient one missing oh great
ones of eating real grain anyone we got
this one over here what's that going to
come down okay now I think I see it
seven because pink right if you want to
start them here because you're free
you're up from zero of the ball will
take you four years to get rid of it
because you're ready to jump one so
therefore that's seven there's no point
of point at your life you can also add
on you can change the regional
monopolies this moment I want the one
that's between there there so that means
it's increased
which means a cup is not sold at home
and then you throw it on and so between
negative one and seven for those values
this inequality issue and of course you
can go ahead and you can put tool
underneath put in X equal zero
will that be true it will right because
our the absolute value of G 4 minus 3
the absolute value of 0 minus 3 of
course it is 3 and that shirt all
business better it will simply check
that and you can check any value in
there and in response